citizens of the reject Nation we are headed
back once more into the further Greg and John
here for insidious the red door chapter five
are you excited sir yes I have only seen the
first two once but we sat down to read the
plot descriptions in detail together John
right we did I remember everything now it's as
if you just saw the movie fresh 10 minutes ago
well guys leave a like for good research
and also subscribe to the channel and hit
the notification Bell to learn when we have more
reactions for you guys to consume thanks to the
folks at prepper for cutting these highlights
down it's tough work and we'd appreciate and
admire them for it and last but not least if
you want to join us for the entire Insidious
The Red Door experience receive every bit
of content that doesn't make these reaction
highlights come on over to patreon.com the real
read Jack sync up with your own copy check out
the other shows we got over there just feel
the love without further ado let's get spooky
[Music]
cool shot yeah good job Patrick Wilson Patrick
Wilson with the interesting ominous upside
down directing definitely taking notes from the
directors who come before you time to keep end
of time throw away who died is it Josh's Mom it's
Tucker and specs in one car that's how they would
demand to be buried they couldn't decide who got
the better plots that they just wanted one often
together it is the mom yeah grandma she misses
you too Kelly dead people don't miss anything
there's so much you have forgotten see you guys
next weekend okay Dalton the POV of uh airpods
part of you you drive him to school you
have a few weeks until all your students
show up nah he wouldn't want me to he's
not the parent you are I mean if you don't
want to then that's a different story
I can't why you're his father force him
oh his name Carl some way that you guys could
connect that's all you know he's been gone soon
so think about it are they not together
anymore that's how it appears right now
where's the movie about their divorce let's
go further into their relationship excuse me
do I know you
whoa I focus appreciate you coming I'm sorry
I grabbed you I got a lot on my mind I'm sure
that floods the mind with memory theme oh no but
there's always new ones to make right other theme
people say we ruin the experiences and
movies what are you guys talking about
oh wow oh wow Patrick Wilson you
and your stylistic text choices
that's crazy they DH Ty Simpkins
to be a baby and it looks flawless
is there someone behind him it
sure looks like it damn that's fun
what the f what the hell is
happening right now [__]
I mean uh serious gotta terrify you this [__] is
happening right now and the slow zoom in too like
oh it's gonna be really close yeah it's gonna
be in the back seat or no it's in the gas pipe
that was spooky uh I hope he keeps that
Steady Hand pace of direction throughout
because I like the deliberateness yeah the
patience behind the shot so far well and
the editing too has an interesting snap about it
like the combination of the shots in the editing
cool opening shots it's making these child
drawings feel Larger than Life [Music]
wow he remembers very iconic
shots from the previous movie
it's okay it's all in the
residual astral you know imprint
you're gonna have to pull out of your little
Funk or it's going to be a long few days
it's well framed for these
text moments welcome to GPU
yeah I'll take one for him
what does jpu stand for just Pazuzu University
it's pretty people are shot way better than the
trailers that made it look I know yeah mom got
you this uh Power Station thing USB port and uh
two jumper cables which are useless yeah you
say that now but you haven't been to the finale
of this movie it was a college dormitory
lots of things we can do with jumper cables
this is intense it's what you've been working
on put it back no it's really good did you do
this for memory I see behaving like
a moody 12 year old I don't know huh
I guess I didn't make the wall huh
where's that shot of you in red face
I'm sorry I haven't been around lately
of course my dad wasn't around at all
but so you should appreciate
my ass I've just been a little
foggy past few years I don't know my brain just
have you ever thought about getting help I'm
just trying to push through yeah I don't need help
this is 1956. I'm not here for your radical ideas
everything cool Phyllis yeah yeah I know just I
thought my roommate would be a um um a white girl
clearly interrupted some
you really don't know me do you I mean you
really think I want to join a frat it's
just a party Dalton I mean do it for me
I drove you here man hey I heard what Mom
said at the funeral well I still did it
oh so that makes you father of the year
now after all we have done for you why don't
you become this ungrateful little [__] uh
no wonder I'll divorce you thanks for the
ride I'll give you a one star rating hey
I like this mature conversation yeah I didn't
feel just like Hollywood tension between them
can feel that an actor directed this way
yeah felt a lot more real I'm liking it so
far something tells me this is gonna be like
the semi Mike Flanagan version of Insidious
yeah that makes sense a little more restrained
less Bonkers yeah story about grief forgiveness
[Music]
oh my mother's just both so out of touch with the
truth and I mean they both are playing a certain
level of like mental kind of fogginess
well low grade [Music] I have a melodica
honestly appear tonight you're in the art
school I take it yeah are you music math
I thought about music but the artist's life is
one of nomadic instability and much gnashing
of teeth amen sister I would say that if
she was also a white woman yes amen lady
[Music]
is that his mom's song it's
just something my mom wrote
yeah from the first we call that a callback people
some weird [__] about you you first on Sundays
I wear monocle and I order takeout with a British
accent that is weird Okay sometimes I eat instant
oatmeal uh with no like water or milk or anything
it's just kind of dry that's gross man I was in a
coma I don't remember anything it's like I woke up
one day and a whole year had passed sure love with
that you would have won this conversation yeah
I've been afraid of the dark seriously sorry
whatever I don't have a sleeping mask oh my
God perfect lighting to illuminate some spooky
scenes to come to keep ghosts obscured [Laughter]
making sure you're getting settled in okay
I don't know what's going on with me but
um I'm gonna find out oh I will say
they really are taking their sweet
time with the building or anything yeah
except that one lady in the back windows
like I'm ready for Spooks now you
know [Laughter] your Technique is
tear it up I worked my ass off on
this piece no one will miss it wow
no way usually I go through introductions before
someone quits I didn't quit yes you did you can go
what an excellent teaching approach there'll
be fifty thousand dollars [Laughter]
how broken you can get
oh whoa what if yours was the only painting she
liked yes why in the hell would you destroy a
beauty beautiful drawing yes I thought it
was the test you must let go of your past
shed your skin in order to grow it's like there's
themes here with each number I want you to think
further and further further why did you say
that further concept everyone she said further
you've got to be willing to dredge
up your ugliest innermost thoughts
all right draw the first two movies do it
draw a cool Mondo poster we can sell later
oh
whoa that got me
oh is that real is it coming out of the
painting you have headphones or you feel
like you need to get out of there give the car
ball a squeeze we'll give you a break all aboard
what a menacing looking MRI rim
[Music]
I mean I guess if you press your ear against it
oh he's gone into the further yeah Dr Brauer
please that's cool hello hey can
you let me out the door is open
get me out of here hello hey
wriggle down oh what the hell what
it's gonna be a hand on your face let me out
what is it always
oh
all the lights went out I
got stuck in there man I saw
uh been asleep for 15 minutes he went right
off your MRI went perfectly you just had a
nightmare man so far the couple of scares
they've had they haven't relied on music
yeah or the I recall the Insidious movies
relying a little bit more on music oh yeah
good news Mr Lambert I guess I was just hoping for
something real something that could explain this
fog it's mental do you have any history of mental
illness in your family not that I'm aware of it's
worth looking into you may be having a mentee
bee you can do stimulate your memory matching
games like like the kids do you always play kids
games do sometimes we can learn a lot from kids
you gotta learn from your
own kid oh man it's a clue
the screenplay's giving you a
clue learn from your kid man
very specific blue lighting to this film yeah
it's like the further is claving in on them oh
it's seeping in from the edges of frame yeah well
in every place in the school is like under lit
by another 10 watt light bulb
oh my God that device is coming in handy
what happened to the light
huh the red desk lamp
just like my old sheets you better clean
that up man you remember that's a yellie
that'll work that'll work
cool not many room assignment today
I'm in 323 now right above you so be
cautious young man unless I hear you
slap your sausage in the dead of night
you will he's a very wacky character this one yeah
I'm excited I heard fight some ghosts we should go
we can make fun of their khaki pants and trust
funds come on Dolphin do something nice for your
old man I offer you some diaper pudding um good
that is the worst themed snack to memorialize the
night that Dalton Lambert actually has fun photo
oh my god do you think something will be in that
photo later on oh no even though no frat is lit
like the further it's a demon party oh no this is
Nick's room and this is Nick's butthole cream I'm
gonna go spread this on the communal Cropper BRB
if Nick comes up there with some I want to Nick
lock the door to this room I especially got money
and then you you okay you need water
or something stop whoa thank you stop
whoa close the door see the guy who died I
need some uh supplies hey Paige I am Nick oh
wait
oh Christ
eyes deceiving me no
no no he just wants to say hi
this is like the Sixth Sense
oh gross gross
we need to go now this is just getting fun
nice nice bro
so sorry we were just looking for some privacy
you know we were gonna do it yeah you should
stick around we might get drunk enough to find
you attractive even though you look like a clown
oh [__] I'm more partial to kick that
oh yeah bro weird inclusion of Comedy
I don't like this framing
stare deeply into the red hues
oh he naturally got there gone
into your own self-induced trance
it's a cool way to re-enter the further officially
yeah it's training like he's lucid dreaming yeah
he's not horrified he's comfortable oh
yeah subconsciously you just
must know this place so well
it's not as good as my room
oh where's my mayonnaise
sound as I was freaky
foreign
way to terrifier you are The Spook now
oh my God
creature is it just like spindly arms I
find my mind going from uh this is boring
and repetitive from things I've seen
too oh my God that's scary [Laughter]
I'm seeing things crazy things that
started with an art exercise dig deep
into a memory and or our subconscious
I drew this door you really need to lay
off the fried juice hey you're the one
who just experienced a weird ass yeah
I feel like I'm getting closer to something
's getting closer to me it's approaching
he's in his underwear yes Patrickson is either
shirtless or in his underwear and he chose to
do it this time that's right it's his call
what was with the focus on two doors you
know one of those doors is a spooky door
and the other door is a Salvation door
it's open now doors with the focus on the door
Insidious House of Doors
are the moms alive as a dead woman you know what I
mean yeah her presence is here
oh she's trying to reach out
uh golly
Dalton Dalton
um memory games good
so he's got some like specific ghosts
that's following him around while Dalton
is literally just hopping it out of the further it
almost feels like the further itself is
calling the Dalton while there's still
what the hell whoa
foreign
why are you running up the stairs damn
I felt very tangible yeah this
River just feels like a guy
creepy nice
you've got the scares man like cheese
yes welcome
good transition that's really how like god-awful
reviews I feel like it got kind of middling review
definitely feels like there's going for
that Mike Flanagan touch yeah leading him
to create this grizzly portrait
of our father devouring his son
damn it's a metaphor dude this art
teacher is like the most app teacher
for his journey he's leading all her
students to become tortured artists
yeah of any true therapeutic help relive
your trauma and I'll see you next week
whoa
I don't want this to sound the wrong way I usually
associate Patrick Wilson as like a dude with a six
pack did he intentionally gain weight for this I
don't know I was wondering that too yeah he looks
just more like regular dad bud yeah I mean I
can see it for the character it makes sense
and doesn't that mean anything to you to
you a red door is that weirder than usual
is this what happens when you go to college
you get all cryptic and [__] I guess
bye bye little brother don't miss you at all we
got your cameo in all grown up don't miss you
that drawing is coming together that is Icky
it's like a Leatherface or something yeah
you're not crazy at all you are an astral
projector oh my oh my www.x YouTube channel
say hi no okay
astral body leaves that physical body and
floats off into another realm it's exactly
what it feels like see I told you it's cool right
you're trying to make this seem like bad editing
but it's pretty good yeah Dr Elise riniak she
had a name for this other realm she called
it the further I'm here to talk to you about
astral projection someone does not age I know
realm and some are doomed to live the worst
mistakes of their lives over and over and
over for all eternity life is what they crave the
further you travel the riskier the journey becomes
yeah and they can come to our world to get
it keep a steady stride creepy YouTube video
was slowly zooming Kim Burns it get a film
student in here to record this what if he
meant something else what if he was talking about
this door so what you want to go back and ask him
hello uh the British accent Hey where's your
monocle what are the chances those bed sheets
are crusty probably snap like a taco shell I'll
take the dirty floor it's acrossier down here
it's crossed everywhere don't open don't
turn on a black light in this room pen
seven damn is that easy for movie
purposes I guess I don't know yeah
I don't know every New Year's man
it must be a nightmare for this guy
on January 1st I don't know why
they're well Traveler it's cool
there's like some Poltergeist elements
to it uh I'm gonna be a while look gross
oh no no no he's in the bathroom
with him while he's doing this yep
it consumes life
Chris guys
dang
oh
no
damn it damn it oh no oh God
come on
wait is she her or she must be her I guess
oh come on
so is every movie of this character just him
rediscovering his past yeah I'm just different
parts of his past in an attempt to protect him
just a different flavor every time I mean kinda
because like Insidious too just like pulls back a
layer of hidden yeah astral memory then lays a new
concealer over it [Music]
what's that your daddy I didn't know
anyone could get hurt in the real world
I can't be a part of this Dalton and neither
should you because next time you might not wake up
I've been there I do feel like the first like
half hour of this had a pretty solid character
development and this has been a little bit
plot beads and stuff yeah it's like a slower
repetitive version of the other movie well yeah
because now we're in the space where we kind of
just know a lot of the stuff they're trying to
cover yeah I know like and I thought they had
some interesting Explorations that I'm still
enjoying it though I don't want I don't want
to be misunderstood like I'm still enjoying it
but I felt like it's losing some of its strengths
I've had this image in my mind for years
we're in a room somewhere like a basement
hello when they frantically edit montages
of people doing very patient activities
uh oh it's Dad Dad from part two that's cool
remember that time Dad went all Jack Torrance
the dad will devour you yes all I ever wanted
was to be better than my father you were you are
Dalton would disagree if it's any consolation I
can't even get him to call me back the acting in
this is really good I would even say better than
the previous ones though yeah that is like one of
its strengths though and like Ty Simpkins growing
up over time like he's doing a great job too I am
angry I've been angry for a long time angry at
a man that I've never met angry at a man that
jumped off the roof of a mental hospital in 1978.
yeah so how in the hell is he terrorizing me here
now he attacked me and Mom's he attacked you yeah
so am I just crazy oh I didn't put that together
yeah I mean it was it was a guess but yeah
confirmed left this for my mom the day he died
oh I wonder if he read some HP Lovecraft this is
very much like an HP Lovecraft story his journey
oh
new number who this save him Chris and I do like
from a oh man I do that from a psychological
standpoint that they're treating the astral
production I heard it's like a mental illness that
passes through the the men so Dalton and I could
travel to some Dimension where we were haunted
by ghosts and goblins or when you put it like
that like the one in those photos that haunted
you back then he told your mom she didn't know
how to help him no I help him like you helped us
by suppressing her memories poof you'd think
they would have an inclination that it would have
something to do with all this [__] I mean yeah
I'm divorcing you and I was too scared to tell
you the truth I'm Gonna Leave You on your own yeah
you deal with the ships raise our kids over here
dolphin deal with it too
but you have kept us away from
away from me why just why why
our family yeah you chased us around the house
with a goddamn baseball bat you just won me over
that's right I forgot about that yeah
I've been lying to our children for
a decade telling them those memories
aren't real dad's not gonna hurt you
oh okay this is good this is finally feeling
like a real sequel I couldn't live like that
anymore yes okay this was like it might be an
hour and 20 minutes the sequel stuff I've been
craving like there we go direct continuation
100 yeah instead of just suppress remember yeah
Dalton just sent this to me something
about a red door what do we do
call Carl Tucker and specs yeah
oh nice cool
embrace the hammer and use it as a tool
this is a different side to the further
yeah the whole different lighting [Music]
it's a good thing you get this memory from
third person point of view here's Joshy
stop just stop
whoa
what the hell this is gonna actually be them
were they trying to say that that's what happened
or it's just a play on his memory I think it's
just a play on the memory I don't think he like
put the hammer there I forget your mind ugh
[Music]
like the opening shot
oh wait is he not him oh oh I would illuminate
your room much like how I illuminate your life
Afraid of the Dark anymore okay well I mean if
you want my opinion don't go digging around in
your past oh yeah some things are just better
left buried you know why is his face actually
morphing I think the longer I mean he just got
possessed but I think the longer possession
lasts because with Patrick Wilson they also
had him with like old lady features Dalton
hey yo I would leave this room you're aware
enough bring some Christmas lights with you
or evil contacts
Misty Blaster onto the bed
uh there you go that's the stuff Dalton
we're gonna get all three
generations in the further
I forget how transport works here
does he just like walk all the way
from their house in the further to the college
we're gonna get out of here and we're
gonna get home yeah that's right I
forgot there's also like time dilation
overlap this movie semi plays like a
Nostalgia hit of the last couple
Insidious yeah remember Insidious
don't be cowards movie killer
off kill her off let's do this
thank you
he's freeing you hey
you tried to kill me they can possess our bodies
it happened to me and now he's done it to you
yeah then you're gonna know what it
really feels like to be blamed for
something that wasn't actually your
fault yeah you got a little [__]
and now you can think of me
Swinging The Hammer to save you
oh yeah oh cool
it Juiced up his mouth effects it's the red door
ew
[Music]
so they just seeped into the real world now
that's what appears to be
happening right now yeah Dad please
this ends with me you go
oh God
maybe the point is to not close the door
I feel like that's that's probably where
we're headed this ends with me hey
I called it yeah everyone look at me
[Music]
that's sad oh and it's still kind of like
the painting in its earlier form okay [Music]
oh yeah painted shut interesting
ugh
[Applause]
say something cool Adam
that's a cool visual yeah that was really
cool visual burn it forget about it
no no forgetting it doesn't work we need to
remember even the things that hurt themes dad
[Music]
I think Patrick Wilson did a really
great job directing I hope he gets an
opportunity to dress like an original script yeah
oh be the light to guide you home
oh okay plot toast it's not him
oh no he kills his wife Dalton
Dalton only attend that one class yep yeah
it's a really relaxed uh structure in terms of how
many units you need per semester hey we're a happy
family again guys hey we're getting back together
and Chris lives with us now see you next Friday
come a little earlier if you want join us
for dinner yeah I'd like that hey thanks I do
think that they missed out on a big thing with not
making it a little bit more about them I mean yeah
I do think they really missed out on that I think
the way he's handled the directing of it is really
great it's it's more like I appreciate the efforts
of the script a lot lovely home oh wait thanks
do you live here I hope so is it her
I guess I've just lost in memories
they can flood the mine yes it's her voice
[Music]
hear that woman on YouTube I know your
mother you have a bright future ahead
you and Dalton keep a steady stride Josh
oh nice I'm just gonna go tell that MRI doctor
he's a quack yeah there was [__] wrong with me
[Music]
Devil Woman [Music]
dad made the wall you think got to have wow
I made the wall
not bad cinematic image
all right Patrick Wilson singing
is it actually his voice yeah he he
collabed with uh that band called ghost
for this cover song apparently
a little self-indulgent here I
know you sang in The Conjuring
too but you don't have to do it
every minute like I'm directing
this I'm singing yeah I stopped getting
naked in movies so now I'm gonna sing
no he's got a lovely voice he does he does but
we could talk about the movie while he sings
this yeah yeah um I enjoyed that quite a bit
you know like I I feel like one thing coming
into this movie for me that that I had to catch
myself on was like you know you get to part five
and something and you're like okay here we go you
know I'm not expecting like necessarily greatness
but remembering back over the franchise I've liked
pretty much every Insidious movie and I feel like
this keeps up a lot of the qualities that even
like the mid chapters you know three and four
that people don't sort of look as fondly on like
those movies both to me had like charms I thought
three was really light probably but I feel like
just as we've got I must look well it's I think it
got good reviews and I think people were pretty
pleased generally I am looking John you talk
while I look I would assert the idea that as we
remove ourselves further in time people probably
further on the first two movies Focus what Greg
does his Interruption the definitive chapters
and then three and four being more auxiliary uh
for various reasons I mean three you had uh lee
1l's directorial debut uh which was certainly you
know fun and Punchy and that movie managed to you
know create something yeah that's like a little
elevated from what the idea would have you kind
of expecting especially based on the idea that
it is like the third in a franchise and so here
coming into this part of me yeah was just sort
of like okay this is a lot of kind of different
Stakes Patrick Wilson's directorial debut we're
on Insidious freaking five now yeah okay so
Insidious two is 39 wowie and cities three is 57
oh oh okay well then I'm uh I must be mistaken
oh [Music] cute little post
credits there the door will return
um but yeah I don't know before I before
I go too far what would you think sir
um now that we've discovered that everyone
apparently loves three a lot more than
part two well actually this has the same Rotten
Tomatoes score as part two okay interesting yeah
people don't love that Lambert
family I guess that's the first one
I think part two is one of those that's been
appreciated in Morris time went on sure I
remembered I never rewatched it because I remember
not really liking it that much okay maybe I was
in the minority at the time like I liked part
two and part two certainly crazier and it goes
after different movie tributes and stuff like
that but I thought it was a step down for sure
no yeah uh I I mean I I feel like I'm uh
I imagine most of our commentary made this
reaction who knows um but I feel like I was making
it pretty clear how it was really feeling about
it throughout uh I do think that the movie
uh there are there are things that I would
find myself going like what is resonating more
with me here on my subjective viewing experience
because there's a lot here that ultimately when
you when you pull it back you go this is a lot
of this is just mainly remember them remembering
the first couple movies but in a really deliberate
film yeah you know yeah like a slower film
without the punch of a Lee one out direction
or a James wand Direction yeah it's not going
for as much of a fun house tone it's going very
much for like a creeping slowly unfolding kind
of thing but with the true emotional substance
not really there until the finale and the First
Act and it's the mid and act two is mainly like
slow deliberate creep stuff but loses
a lot of that Nuance that is present
in the First Act in the third act and I
think what it was really seeing for me
it's like the father-son story I think they
should have had them interacting a little bit more
together instead of telling just to completely
separate plot lines with them and because then
it's just them on their own going I'm starting
to remember the first movies you know yeah that's
what they're essentially doing with a little bit
of Patrick Wilson going my dad and and then uh
and then I think they should have dealt more I
was like I loved what they just included it's
so late if they did deal with that of of like
oh they're divorced what happened you know yeah
and them really dealing with the repercussions of
what the dad did in the second movie you know and
and the kid and it's like they only had that with
Dalton who had this angst about it instead of the
other kids and I'm like oh there's there seems
like there was a more I feel like there could
have been a way more interesting movie while
still doing like because like I said the Patrick
Wilson's directing I thought was really good I
thought the shots look great like on the trailers
it looked like some weird straight to DVD [__]
yeah and and when watching the actual movie like
no this looks this looks really good yeah it's
great looking film and and it's well edited he's
got a great sense of Aura and tone and yeah it's
well edited and the scares are actually quality
I thought they were good quality scares the only
thing that kind of hampers it is at times you're
like yeah this is since the other movies yeah
just shot different it's the same it's the like
we're just redoing the same kind of scare but
just a different type of Direction on it which
it's understandable for a sequel to Insidious and
going back into the further but the plot context I
thought could have just been so much more Dynamic
and and just overall like it's the most simplistic
term just way more engaging if they did have more
of that uh interaction where that's where the real
meat of the story was and then and clearly that's
what the movie's even saying at the end here
but they introduce it so late yeah as a thing
that like oh that would have just made a more
interesting movie if this is what they're dealing
with instead of like that same beat all over again
what I have a thing from my past and I'm gonna
like we're doing this we're doing it again just
just with a different mood wrapped around it
you know yeah it's interesting like I admire
the choice and I think there I think yeah it's
like I can imagine an alternate version of this
script where you have them still learning about
the situation and filling in the the gaps for
themselves on their own but there was something
I said early on and I think we even joked about
it the whole like it was gonna be an awkward few
days if we're not talking to each other and part
of me was like if you had it such that he was
gonna be however far away you know the school
is from where they live like okay he's gonna be
there for like a week or something so it's like
they could get distance from each other but be
very close together for some of the emotional
beats of this because yeah it's like without that
in the middle you do feel like okay we're kind of
it's not as good as like the sum of its parts in
that section because yeah it's like it's they're
doing fine work watching the individual plot lines
layout but then that stuff becomes a lot more nuts
and bolts and a lot more creeping toward things
that we already kind of know are coming I guess
well it's because when you when you get that final
moments uh when he when he finally meets up with
Rose Byrne that actually introduces a tangible
ingredient of something they have to overcome yeah
on an emotional core level on a physical level
whereas most of the movie prior to like the last
20 minutes yeah is that I'm just I'm trying to
remember yeah something yeah yeah yeah and I gotta
gotta go in and out of the further to get there I
guess yeah and and we know them and the thing
is it's not that Mis it's not mysterious yeah
because we know the mystery we know what they're
trying to unpack we know the answer so it's not as
interesting as it looks you know and if you'd had
him uncovering like I like the whole thing with
the painting and the way it's like slowly taking
shape and like oh there's a face and it's all you
know vague and distorted like I feel like there
would have been a way maybe to amplify the effects
of him finally realizing oh [__] that's dad the
memory is all coming back in a situation where
Patrick Wilson as a character is a bit closer in
proximity and closer in terms of just like the
direct link between their two stories as they
unfold or something like that like yeah it's I
I liked where it got to and I thought those scenes
were great and like for her brief appearances I
thought Rose Byrne did a terrific job and that's
something I remember about the first movie too is
they had a really nice sense of like cross talk
with each other and like those kind of intimate
family Vibes they missed that I think it's I
think that's a missing ingredient here yeah
um yeah it's weird it's like it makes sense as to
why these things would happen and I thought it was
funny we're sitting there going like yeah you know
you kind of left him a lot well he did try to like
Massacre your whole family this has been very
very traumatic but at the same time having it
it's weird it's like I admire the choice of this
being the father-son story mostly focusing on them
I like the choice that they have at least the one
brother uh sort of at least kind of involved on
the periphery but there is something about like
that family unit I feel like we experienced them
mostly in the memorial and then in flashback
and it would have been nice to have like that
family unit a little more vital throughout or
something yeah yeah because I like I said the
the purpose to of of tuber the purpose to
remember I think we needed a little bit of
clarity on like if you think about the first
movie the purpose to remember is I gotta get
my son out of where he's trapped he's not in a
coma yeah you know yeah I have to save him yeah
um it's not just about remembering for remembering
sake because my mind is bothered by some [__]
and like you need that actual thing to thrust the
movie forward and so it does feel as great as the
movie actually looks and as solid as the acting
is uh from everyone here and I like and like I
like some of the deeper nuances they're aiming for
for the commentary on mental health and repression
and all that jazz like it's a more um at times on
the nose but I think for the most part I'm a more
uh I guess a more mature handling of it than the
previous ones it's the rare movie like this where
I feel like the subtext is like really well intact
and then just some of like the actual immediate
plot beats like could do better accentuating that
yeah yeah yeah yeah because especially like for my
benefit I have only I haven't really I don't I've
only seen the second one once and I I think I've
seen the first one twice yes I must have because
I saw it at home I saw it in the theaters and then
when we saw the second one I think we went to a
double feature right yeah yeah I remember that
when that happened and it didn't help because
the second one you know like the second one
oh yeah don't worry it's not as bad as the time
I saw all the five die hards in the same day sure
because that Marathon got really challenging yes
that's like the main missing thing for me was um
the potential of the movie really finally became
Crystal Clear when she introduced that I'm like
oh I've only just been a much more interesting
film yeah if it was like you know you try to do
something or like the kids are all like if if he
was just like shunned from the family and the kid
because I only got the sense that Dalton had an
issue with him I didn't get the sense the other
kids had an issue with like or at least the other
son it makes sense for Cali or whatever the like
the daughters was not involved in it no this is
my all intents and purpose she's a baby right in
the first round yeah and so unless it's like truly
let genetic thing but yeah it's like Foster should
at least have some uh I don't know yeah I didn't
read as much like a trauma and especially when he
comes in on the both of them it just seemed like
oh it's just Mom and Dad or if there was like a
thing of like where did we go wrong like Patrick
Wilson doesn't know and like Rose Byrne is like
there's like an anguishing conflict about like I
I want to be able to talk to you about this but
I I can't it's you know you can't it's dangerous
you know like I was like damn there's such a meaty
thing there yes because I didn't quite get like
what the point of them trying to remember other
than was like okay is the further just trying
to seep back in and it's like it had it had its
character arcs and psychological things on its
mind but in terms of making the actual journey
through it more Dynamic especially on an Insidious
level it Grant I haven't seen the fourth one so I
don't know how like terrible then that's about
what everyone said I mean I thought it was it's
probably I know it's I know it's like the one that
I thought it was pretty decent I know it's the one
that people like the least um I've never seen that
one yeah I mean it's I I think just in a nutshell
it's still in fitting with the like oh okay this
is going for some emotionally uh motivated stuff
and then lots of jump scares and yada yada it's
probably the most sort of uh side questy feeling
of all of them it's I like that one because it
was like about Elise and it was like her movie to
lead uh which I thought was new but the opening of
this film that was the actual ending of part two
I'm looking at the footage of them I don't know
that's a lot of the best de-aging and digital
creation of Thai Simpkins yeah totally
oh because I don't remember that at all
um because yeah to repress that because yeah like
I like the context of that of oh what happens when
you just try to repress it um yeah instead of like
you you would this was a natural fitting plot for
that but it just ultimately does feel repetitive
um but no I mean other than me just sounding
repetitive here uh I think Ty Simpkins is great
I actually enjoyed the presence of that new girl
Chris was great yeah I thought she was fun and
brought life to it and her entire Simpkins had
a great back and forth and I like their friendship
well I like that I found that very endearing even
if that part even if the middle of the movie does
kind of sag under the weight of like we're just
kind of running around and figuring stuff out and
trying to remember things like I really like their
Rapport I thought her involvement with the plot
was relatively conscientious in terms of just
how characters respond to things overall
um and and yeah like I I really appreciated
um or you know what I think could have could have
helped I don't know I feel like because they had
the whole divorce thing it's like you could have
kind of opened up throughout the middle I feel
like you could have involved Rose Byrne to a
point where it's like she and Patrick Wilson
are trying to figure this out together because
he's clearly trying to make progress on this
um I don't know yeah it's like it's like if you
just moved the crest into act three further back
to being there for act two or something yeah if
they learned all that [__] halfway through and
then we started again because then it's parts
of the finale especially because it seems like
the movie's gonna be when it first starts off it
seems like it's going to be an even displacement
even placement of scenes between Patrick Wilson
and Ty Simpkins yeah and then at a certain point
it's like it's like mainly Ty Simpkins yes
sometimes it's magic Wilson if you'd had him
and her figuring this [__] out and then like or
even him testing was calling Rose Byrne you know
I don't know why they didn't involve her it feels
like a scheduling thing she's like barely in this
movie yeah but she's clearly as committed as she's
been before and I feel like there could have been
a greater enhancement of it's funny that it's
one of those reviews where I'm like I like most
everything about this movie generally but it does
kind of leave you thinking about a couple ways in
which it could have been great and yeah it's like
I think they could have also made more out of the
sense of distance if you'd had those Stakes
kind of going sooner because it's like you've
got Patrick Wilson doing his astral experience in
one place and then Dalton in a different location
and that is neat as it's presented but I think
could have been like a much grander source of
tension or something especially if you've got
the family sort of I don't know you'd have that
extra layer of their relationship reforming
and maybe them getting past some trauma the
family kind of confronting this and strengthening
together and then rather that being like the sort
of end destination you could have that be part of
their Journey as we then get to this yet to prong
sort of further Journey um but either way yeah I
really liked uh the returning cast Chris was great
um you know and the different flourishes of
like the demons the Tiny Tim stuff coming
back there's like not much in the way
of like further ghosts and things but I
always enjoy the aesthetic of the further
nice to see Tucker in specs for a second
at least for a second I mean like it's it's it's
their franchise altogether in a lot of ways I feel
like it's been her franchise up until this point
so this was kind of a neat sort of torch pass or
or at least a way to like wrap it up in a way it's
like Beyond her um and yeah like I thought it's
funny it is something I notice in movies of like
when they have like art and artists and students
and and Fine Arts and things like that like it
can be kind of Hit or Miss in terms of like what
really just reads authentically and I thought they
had a lot of like really neat art designs in this
um and yeah it's like for what it is I appreciate
it it's like I like the script they came up with
and the story they come up with and it didn't
seem like anything was lazy necessarily but it
does feel like this is one option out of a few
options for how to present the story I guess
yeah and I don't remember who they said was
credited on the script but I'm looking it up
right now but yeah like I thought Scott teams I've
heard that name I think is a Conjuring writer or
something like that he did Halloween kills red
face dies tonight uh he did Fire Starter oh good
that was well received I mean His Highest
ones when we were called that Evening Sun
I don't know what this is though okay I mean I
thought this was a a nicely done directed as well
there's a solid like as far as like scripts I have
gripes about go I thought this was like you know
it breathed nice this themes are a bit loud but
they're there and they make a lot of sense and
I do appreciate the yeah just the rumination on
like generational inherited traumas mental illness
Etc the way that comes out through ART um and I
feel like that's kind of its own sort of trophy
environment is like the big sort of cavernous art
class room where we're gonna do a lot of like dark
emotional work and stuff and then the cutting
back and forth and the painting actually being
part of the experience there like this is a bit
maybe muddier in terms of like the rules of the
further because too you have like the scene where
the demons are just all grabbing Chris and you're
like what are the wait what exactly how does this
work well I think that there was a an element of
depth that they were teasing us with and I just
think that depth gets so lost yeah into just
remember again I'm sorry I don't mean literal
fact finders yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
um that's and and so to me that's where my
disappointment of it comes in because that
was like the first 23 minutes I was like oh you
know there's something really interesting here
yeah and then never mind yeah yeah we're gonna
we're gonna divide the family up and then we're
gonna divide the two core units of the family
up and then we're gonna have like parallel plot
lines until we get back to yeah meshing again
yeah yeah because because even because I even
feel like Patrick Wilson's Journeys um hampered
by he doesn't remember to like the last until he
meets about the Rose Burns like he's back in the
further he's handling I'm like oh well now he just
got like we skipped over a whole journey that's
what I'm saying yeah it's like if you'd involved
her with the medical situation and his mind you
know attenuation games and stuff like that like
I don't know yeah I think you could have a lot
more gradually developed these themes rather than
it feeling like oh yeah they kicked uh back into
gear all of a sudden when we got like this big
burst of breakthrough character energy yeah yeah
because I'm not even here being like Oh I wanted
more fun scary stuff you know uh like I like the
fun scary stuff and I think it's hideous that's
one of its earmarks so perhaps that is a thing
that is if it can be a little listless I imagine
uh for people when it comes to this movie but
for myself I don't know I'm I I tend to be more
of like a Mike Flanagan lover uh this is where
I'm just like yeah just be deep dark drama movies
for what this is I thought it it was I think it
postures as that as a spook house as a deep dark
as a deep drama sure yeah sure sure there are
certainly better choices they could have made
if they really wanted this to be a deep dark
drama and uh and that thing that goes back to
the script though yeah yeah yeah totally because
it's it's excuse I can see it in that mechanic of
like its reasons to get them alone isolated and
into situations where you can have these tents
looking around jump scare kind of moments that
we all associate with it's harder to do that
in a group scenario um and and yeah but I mean
for whatever friction is caused by the amount
of depth or not the script is going for I thought
the horror moments the horror Aesthetics the the
characters we see like the dead frat guy um you
know the moments in the further with the fog and
the crazy rooms like I of that stuff all still
carried the aura and I thought the actual scare
moments were all pretty well effective because
two I remember especially at the height of you
know the sort of more recent ghost haunting
movie boom it started to become a meme to me
like especially watching like the original nun
trailer or even Insidious 4 you're like okay
so how many different versions of like let's pan
back and forth and try and misdirect your eye and
all that stuff before we eventually jump out at
you can we do and I thought this managed to have
interesting fun jump scares that didn't feel like
they were trying too hard or forced to bend over
backwards I think that's a good credit to give
the movie was it nor does it feel like just some
afterthought like I like the MRI scare a lot yeah
it lets you live in that moment yeah without it
again I respected when they didn't rely on music
there was good jump scares there's effective stuff
here and I like that Patrick Wilson was here to
Showcase his directing skills without trying to be
like I'm I want to I want to make you a terrifying
film yeah it's like he clearly learns stuff and
the the scares and the amount of horror stuff like
proportionately I think matches the type of story
this particular movie is well half of his films he
made what James wants so yeah he must have learned
and learned a lot about using Hot Heads you learn
a lot about moving camera I believe five movies
at least right It's gotta be five that's your
Insidious two conjurings and an Aquaman yeah
so he's done five I mean unless there's one I'm
forgetting that James won directed but he's oh
well I mean he's the lost kingdom um but if that
ever sees the legend yeah it really doesn't like
him he does a [__] boy yeah yeah that's the
dude yeah James really likes working with this
guy yeah it's like number one guy right there
when I cast you in two very similar franchises
and then take you on my Blockbuster Adventure yeah
that's kind of crazy yeah it really really does
get along with that guy yeah hey you know you find
your Muse and uh James Salon found Patrick Wilson
alrighty um it's pretty good leave us your
thoughts what did you guys think are you
in cities fan did this movie live up to your
expectations where would you rank it in the
pantheon of insidii leave us your thoughts
and before we get out of here let's do up
Gabriel burn I'm assuming your last name
is burn because Rose Burn is in this movie
Booyah and if there's anybody I'd love to come
home to in a state of traumatic distress to be
comforted by Gabriel that'd be you I feel
like you could calm me you could provide me
with the emotional and intellectual details to
soothe my quandary and put me back on the path
toward the light does anyone call you Gabby
Gaby gab Gabe Gabriel Gibby ooh Gibby I like
Gibby huh you know there's other variations
in her name like gabrian Gabriella Gabrielle
Gabriel gavril gavril that's a cool one huh
anyone call you that let's try one more time
Gabby Gaby Gabe Gabriel Gibby gabrin Gabriela
Gabriel Gabrielle Gabriel say that 50 times
fast jeez get Gibby get I can just keep coming
back Gabby gabri that's the one I wanted Gibby
how many of these names make uh shortening like
negate the point of shortening a name by making
it more complicated choose your favorite nickname
Gabriel do you have one is it just Gabe you should
get some more original like Gibby or uh you know
or give me give me Gabriel gaberson whatever it
is you let us know what you want to be called and
uh and we will neither assume you religious nor a
simple Gabriel nor Gabe you will be the most
uniquely named person at this patreon so uh
keep on the straight and narrow stay out of the
astral plane and uh stay pledged though in fact
if you want to Pledge on this plane and pledge in
the astral plane just to cover yourself for all of
time to come it's a good idea but anyway we love
you here love you love you Gabriel Gabby Gabriel
[Music]